hello everyone and welcome back to the
legend of chess tournament on chess24
it's the finals and in the finals we
have a match between yanni ponchi and
magnus carlson this is the first game of
match one it just finished and
we are about to show it uh for some
reason there's a b
here where r should be uh so let me just
fix that there we go just
fixing that r all right there we go
all better uh so uh jan with the white
pieces opens with
e4 and magnus of course goes for the
sicilian we have c5
knight to f3 d6 and now d4
and i haven't uh followed live right
from the beginning but someone mentioned
on twitter that
jan took like over a minute to decide um
on the d4 move i don't know if it's true
but if it is it's uh very interesting
uh could be that he was he was deciding
whether to go maybe bishop to b5
or or something else uh see captures we
have knight captures knight to f6 knight
to c3 and a6 magnus goes again for the
knight of variation of the sicilian
and here uh so many moves are possible
but nipple goes for
for could be the most interesting one
rook the g1 immediately preparing g4 and
g5
and the magnus took some time here to
decide whether he would uh
defend this well maybe to just play h5
to block it
uh because if g5 will not be able to
capture the
white will gladly give up the rook for
two pieces so that's not an issue
so here magnus decides for b5 he allows
the pushing of g4 g4 we have g4 and
bishop to b7 with a double attack on the
pawn here
but nepo says be my guest and
you know just grab the pawn and the
problem with grabbing the pawn
is that there is no problem in grabbing
the pawn uh however there is
because after captures captures and
captures let's say
queen here and you go back or something
like that f4
uh magnus would be up upon but he would
be playing basically against an engine
because nepo has this
analyzed at home and he knows every top
reply and
well magnus will just have to spend a
lot of time a lot of time to refute
every move
uh and in the end it will you know it
will it could be
become a problem for him so instead of
grabbing the e4 pawn he just goes knight
d7 he says i'm not interested in your
engine moves let's uh play normal chess
with a3 stopping b4 and now g6 by magnus
preparing to fianchetto the dark square
bishop
with h4 by nipple and bishop to g7 and
here there is one game in the
in the database where bishop the e3 was
played but here nepal goes for h5
and it is already as of movie 11 that we
have a completely new game so as you can
see magnus finn carrying his bishop's
nipple pushing g5 h5
the way modern chess is played so knight
to c6 with a double attack on the knight
magnus just develops and bishop to e3
defending we have knight to c5
now with more pressure on the e4 pawn
and now f3
just defending that pawn with castles by
magnus he says i'm not worried about
anything you're gonna do here on the
king side if you push
i don't mind i can just move the bishop
and if you capture which is what nepo
did magnus captured with the f-pawn
usually you want to capture uh towards
the center but here
opening up the uh f-file for the rook is
quite significant as nepal's king is
still in the center of the board
so here nepal trades once we have knight
captures on c6 bishop characters and the
bishop to h3 now
uh and uh well just asking black what do
you do here and here magnus decides to
give up his strong dark square bishop
uh to mess up nepo's pawn structure on
the queen side and uh
well get uh get get rid of white's
control over over the d5 square so
bishop captures on c3 b captures and
e5 now uh sorry first b captures and e5
i thought i captured and now with
complete control here of the
uh d4 square and you might have some
ideas here of going knight a4
could have some uh very nice threats
here uh so here we have bishop to g4
now guarding the pawn so the so the
queen can move and now
queen to e7 developing the queen and
connecting rooks with
queen to d2 uh and now rook a to d8 and
now ideas like d5 are definitely coming
so nepo stops it with c4 says i now have
control of d5 but
b captures on c4 and now queen side
castles
and it's a very interesting position
where probably best for magnus is knight
to a4
with with the threat of just uh c3s is
possible d5 followed by queen captures
an a3 is possible
so white would have to go for something
like queen before but then c3 and
black would get a very nice position
however magnus goes for a different
idea he goes knight to e6 uh
and here queen to c3 getting the queen
away from the from the d
file and then now bishop to d7 uh you
could also defend the pawn with bishop
to b5 but magnus doesn't want to play
passively he even welcomes the idea of
the c file or opening up
for his rook so instead he moves the
bishop back bishop to d7
as after the queen captures there will
be a double attack on the knight so
queen captures and king g7 now just
unpinning the king from this diagonal
now the knight can move and queen back
to b4
now not allowing d5 or anything like
that since the queen hangs
with knight to f4 with some very
interesting tricks here knight to e2
check winning the winning the rook
there's also an attack on the bishop
here
so you have to decide what to do here
you're not quite in time to capture this
pawn
so here we have bishop captures on f4
nepo has to eliminate the knight but now
first the bishop captures on g4
and now we have rook captures and g4
rook captures on f4
rook captures and pawn captures and
sorry
and now not pawn captures but rather uh
an even better move this was a
an automatic capture by me but instead
magnus played queen captures on g5 first
he gets rid of the g5 pawn the rook is
pinned you cannot move it and you're
gonna capture it on the next move
so here rook captures on d6 by nipple
and now queen captures with
check king b1 and now rook captures and
d6 queen captures and
h5 magnus starts pushing his pass pawn
and here we have an end game where the
material is completely equal
and it's a question whether uh nepo c
pawn is faster than
carlsen's h pawn so nipple of course
starts pushing at c4 you don't even care
about the pawn you want to get this pawn
rolling as fast as possible
magnus captures it's a spur of the
moment thing i guess
when you decide to capture like this
instead of just starting to push your
pawn but magnus
uh i guess realized that he will be able
to stop this and it never hurts being up
a pawn in an end game
so here a queen captures an e5 uh
winning the pawn back
uh so nepo also uh waiting with the pawn
pushing queen to f6 uh and now you
cannot trade queens if you trade then
you all know the
the square of the pawn rule uh if uh the
if the king is not in the square of the
pawn of course the king will not be able
to reach that pawn
and the king is two moves away from from
the square of the pawn so black spawn
will be able to queen
whereas white's pawns will be easily
stopped by the black king
so instead after queen f6 we have queen
d5 by nepo
and now h4 magnus starts pushing his
pass pawn and nepo does the same
ah but now queen to f1 with check
king a2 slowly magnus connects a few
checks queen g2 check
king to b3 and now queen g3 check king
to a4
and now that the king is on a very uh
very bad square only now magnus
continues pushing his pass pawn nepo
does the same
like we said it's a race between the h
and the c pawn and
h2 now preparing the queen uh so of
course queen to d7 check nepo starts
checking the
black king king to h6 and now nepo's
only
only hope is to go queen d2 check and
after king moves then continue checking
the kinking
queen to d1 check and so on and if this
works then it works if not
then it doesn't however nepal tried a
trick here queen to d8
he said okay if you queen i'm just going
to play queen check here you're going to
move the king and queen captures
here but there is a problem to napo's
queen to d8 idea
so feel free to pause the video and win
the game here for magnus while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on noticing that
the queen must be
centralized and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show uh it's
queen to e5 and this is just a beautiful
move
attacks this pawn stops queen to h8 and
most importantly threatens queen to b5
checkmate as
the king has nowhere to go from there so
nepo
of course cannot afford something like
this just ends in checkmate so he has to
do something he goes for queen to h4
check
king g7 and now king to b3 you have to
waste the move like this and
so you don't get checkmated but now
queen b5 check
and now the problem with going for
example behind the pawn or something
like this
is that black can easily remaneuver the
queen with a few checks to
guard the h1 square and now i have to
remove the king just bring the queen
into the game and now
of course it's game over for white so
instead of queen c3 by nepo but now
queen captures on c6 would check king d3
queen d6 check king e2 and now queen
captures on a3
again a little joke uh for the end
magnus says that if you capture i just
play queen a2 check and win your queen
so here uh we have king to f2 but now
queen to b to check
king to g3 and now queen to f6 offering
a queen trade
of course nipple cannot accept the queen
trade the a pawn is much too fast
so queen h3 but now as the king has been
aligned with the queen
just queen to c3 check and it was
in this position that ian imported
resigned the game and the game one of
the
legends of chess uh tournament ends by
magnus winning
and nepo now needs to retaliate to get
back into the match
so here of course you resign because
after captures captures and captures
it's two to one with the a pawn being
much too fast for
for white king to even start approaching
and of course there's no point in
playing this
so after queen to c3 nepal resigns and
game one goes to magnus
uh so yeah a very very interesting stuff
nepo really did some
uh you know a nice preparation there
with the rook to g1
uh was a very very very exciting line uh
but then
i think uh magnus just annoyed him too
much when when he didn't want to go for
this captures because nepo is a
very exciting player he always likes you
know when when stuff is happening on the
board and he was hoping
for this but then magnus just declined
his offer
uh you know so politely and uh
then you know then it was a normal
position where white was slightly better
but magnus doesn't mind if you're
slightly better
uh once again i do hope you enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank um john hart
uh arun kumar uh arumugam uh harshid
gosh don dugan and
jeff graves for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it uh as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and i will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the chess 24 legends of chess tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day